I think we're all born with a deep and
meaningful purpose that we have to
discover your purpose in life is not
something you need to make up it's
already there when you make being
grateful a habit you'll feel true joy
and contentment no matter what you have
or don't have in your life almost
everyone I work with has a goal to have
more money yet the simple fact is there
are really only two ways to end up with
more money need motivation watch a top
10 of the leave nation what's up at 7 my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and show
in today's lessons from a man who has
the Guinness Book of World Records for
having 7 books on the New York Times
bestseller list at the same time he's
Jack Canfield and here's my take on his
top ten rules a success volume to enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one discover your passion first
and foremost you need something bigger
than you to be inspired about I think
we're all born with a deep and
meaningful purpose that we have to
discover your purpose in life is not
something you need to make up its
already there you just need to discover
it that means to take the cover off of
what's already there and when you do
when you really discover what you're
meant to do it will be the reason you
get up in the morning prior discovering
your life purpose it's easy to become
sidetracked or feel uninspired or feel
like you've accomplished very little in
life but what if these feelings are
simply feedback that you need to keep
going keep searching until you discover
and what if it's the universe reminding
us not to settle for mediocrity to
continue experimenting for the one thing
that lights you up I also believe we're
all born with a set of talents and
interests that tell us what we're
supposed to be doing lots of times they
come so naturally to us we overlook them
we think finding our purpose is supposed
to be more profound or difficult but
what if it's right in front of you the
whole time think about it have you ever
wanted to study something that you loved
but the more logical route was to do
what your parents or teachers or friends
thought you should do well maybe you
wanted to be a Potter or a musician or
an artist but ended up in business
school because it was logic or sensible
if so you're not alone you're just off
track maybe you really are meant to be a
Potter rule number two
step out of your comfort zone you know
most people want certain things in life
a nice home a comfortable bank account
or awarding career vibrant health and
loving relationships they wish that life
was better or that they could have more
or that things were somehow different
they might even know the steps they need
to take to get there but something
stopping them now what keeps people
stuck in their comfort zone driving with
the brakes with him well I'll tell you
it's the negative images you have about
yourself or the effects of toxic
experiences that you have a process
yet perhaps this describes you staying
in a comfort zone entirely of your own
making maintaining flawed beliefs about
yourself or holding on to guilt and
self-doubt when you try to achieve your
life goals these negative images and
pre-programmed comfort zones that you
find yourself stuck in always seem to
cancel out your good intentions no
matter how hard you try so what if
instead of using willpower is the engine
to power your success you simply release
the brakes by letting go of your
limiting beliefs and changing the images
you hold about yourself you see
unfortunately most people just continue
to live in their same old comfort zone
and then complain about their experience
rather than doing something about it and
by continually complaining about
thinking about and writing about the way
things are you're continually
reinforcing those same neural pathways
on your brain that got you to where you
are today and they're gonna keep you
stuck there if you don't change them so
to change the cycle you've got to focus
instead on thinking talking and writing
about the reality you want to create
you've got to flood your unconscious
with thoughts and images of your desired
new reality and one way to do this one
way to stretch your comfort zone is to
bombard your subconscious and
unconscious minds with new thoughts and
images of what you want images of a
bigger bank account a trim healthy body
exciting work interesting friends of
memorable experiences rule number three
is get rid of negative energy we also
know from polygraph or lie detector test
that your body reacts to your thoughts
changing your temperature heart rate
blood pressure breathing rate muscle
tension and how much your hand sweat
when you're hooked up to a lie detector
and our ask the questions such as did
you take the money your hands will get
colder your heart will beat faster your
blood pressure will go off your
breathing will get faster your muscles
might get tighter and your hands might
sweat if you take if you did take the
money and you lie about it now these
kinds of physiological changes occur not
only when you're lying but also in
reaction to
single thought you think every cell in
your body is affected by every thought
you have now negative thoughts affect
your body negatively weakening you
making a sweat and making you uptight
positive thoughts affect your body in a
positive way making you more relaxed
more centered more open and alert
positive thoughts cause the secretion of
endorphins in the brain and reduce pain
and increase pleasure
psychiatrist Daniel G Eamon has named
the limiting thoughts we hear in our
head ants amts
automatic negative thoughts and just
like real ants at a picnic your ants can
ruin your experience of life dr. Ayman
recommends that you learn to stomp the
ants first you have to become aware of
them next you have to shake them off and
stomp them by challenging them and
finally you have to replace them with
more positive affirming thoughts the key
to dealing with any kind of negative
thinking is to realize that you're
ultimately in charge of whether to
listen to and agree with any thought or
to not now just because you think it or
hear it doesn't mean it's true you want
to constantly ask yourself is this
thought helping me or is this thought
hurting me is it getting me closer to
where I want to go or is it taking me
further away is it motivating me to
action or is it blocking me with fear
and self-doubt you have to learn to
challenge and talk back to the thoughts
that are not serving you in creating
greater success and Happiness rule
number four my personal favorite get rid
of your limiting beliefs
now another mistake you might have
normally be making and therefore
sabotaging your own happiness with is
allowing yourself to be controlled by
your limiting beliefs
many of us have beliefs that limit our
success whether their beliefs about our
own capabilities beliefs about what it
takes to succeed or even beliefs about
how they should relate to other people
now moving beyond your limiting beliefs
is a critical step toward becoming
happier and more successful and there
you must first believe that you're
capable of accomplishing your goals and
you're capable of being happy and here's
a simple but powerful four-step process
you can use to transform any limiting
belief into an empowering belief the
first step is identify a limiting belief
that you want to change the second step
is to determine how that belief is
limiting you now the third step is to
decide how you would rather be act or
feel and a fourth step is to create a
turnaround statement that affirms or
gives you permission to be to act or to
feel this new way for example a negative
belief might be if I express my true
feelings people will think I'm weak and
take advantage of me
now the turnaround belief would be the
more I express my true feelings the more
people love respect admire and support
me now once you've created a new belief
you will need to implant it into your
subconscious mind through constant
repetition for 2 or 3 minutes several
times a day for a minimum of 30 days
rule number 5 is play the appreciation
game many people find that it requires
great diligence to cultivate a
persistent attitude of appreciation
that's because we've been culturally
conditioned to focus on what we don't
have
rather than appreciation for what we've
already received and achieved when you
make being grateful a habit you'll feel
true joy and contentment no matter what
you have or don't have in your life
instance the law of attraction states
that like attracts like being grateful
will naturally attract more into your
life that you can be grateful for it
becomes a never-ending cycle of
positivity now we do dozens of things
every day on autopilot such as eating
our meals taking showers or doing the
dishes and we don't have to spend time
visualizing these activities or putting
them on our to-do lists we simply do
them out of habit
now playing the appreciation game on a
daily basis will help you turn gratitude
into a daily habit so you can attract
more joy and more abundance into your
life all year long now here's how the
appreciation game works first set aside
a specific time each day to consciously
appreciate everything you encounter
everything you look at everything you
see now an ideal time to do this is on
your way to or from work secondly
appreciate the people you pass the road
you walk on the cars will let you merge
into a different Lane the street signs
that make it easy for you to know where
you're going the rain that's nurturing
the plants and the trees of soem and
third look for the good in all
situations even those you would normally
view as negative as the saying goes
every cloud has a silver lining
rule number six is create more value
almost everyone I work with has a goal
to have more money yet the simple fact
is that there are really only two ways
to end up with more money you could
either spend less or you can make more
now personally I'm a fan of making more
I'd rather make more and have more money
to spend and always be denying myself
the things that I want in our lifetime
most of us been confronted with having
to figure out how to spend less money
you can think about what you can cut out
here and what you can cut out there and
what you cut back on and you're
constantly focusing on what you have to
get rid of now this is a good exercise
if you're doing it once a year as you
review your budgets but not something I
could recommend daily I recommend
thinking about money differently what if
instead of focusing on lack not having
enough and how to cut back you were to
focus on ways to make more either by
doing more of what's currently working
or finding opportunities that you just
haven't had the time to consider yet now
this type of thinking opens up all kinds
of possibilities for you so the first
step in making more money is to ask
yourself how much more money you want to
earn or have
and once you've decided how much more
you want to make you have to realize
that the only way to make more money is
to provide more value to more people so
ask yourself what product service or
additional value can I deliver to earn
the additional money that I want and
once you've identified that and commit
to taking the time to strategically plan
develop and deliver that product at
service or that extra value rule number
seven eliminate bad habits now to become
successful you'll need to eliminate bad
habits and develop new ones that are
more in alignment with the life you want
to live now the life you want to live
will not just materialize one day your
habits determine your outcomes so what
are the habits that you live with every
day that are keeping you from achieving
your goals I want you to be honest with
yourself here are you always running
late do we turn phone calls within 24
hours are you getting enough sleep
do you follow through on your promises
if you plan out your day and then work
your plan now if you don't well just
imagine what your life would be like if
all your habits were productive and
future focused what would your life be
like if you ate healthy meals exercise
and got enough sleep what if you save
the money stop using your credit cards
and paid cash for everything what if you
stop procrastinating and overcame your
fears and begin networking with people
in your field
would you like be different I promise
you it will be so my suggested extra
step for you is to write down some
productive habits that you could
visualize then adopt in your life will
number 8 create your mastermind group
you know one of the most powerful tools
ever used by successful people is called
the mastermind group Napoleon Hill first
talked about mastermind groups in his
classic book Think and Grow Rich and
it's the one concept people most
reference when they credit any one thing
with helping them become a millionaire
Andrew Carnegie had a mastermind group
so did Henry Ford in fact Ford would
bastard mine with Brian thinkers like
Thomas Edison and Harvey Firestone and
others in a group they held at their
winter mansions in Coral Gables Florida
they knew as millions of others have
discovered since that a mastermind group
can focus special energy on your effort
in the form of knowledge resources and
even spiritual energy - so why you must
always do the work of becoming a great
success a mastermind group can harness
and maximize the spiritual focus behind
your success and it's this spiritual
aspect that Napoleon Hill wrote about
extensively in fact he says if we are to
tune in with the mastermind that is God
or if you want to call it universal
power infinite intelligence Source
Energy or whatever term you use for this
all-powerful lifeforce
we have significantly more positive
energy available to us when we do that
power that can be focused on our success
now what's an example of how this works
we have probably seen bumper cars at a
local theme park or a carnival and this
life force is similar to the web of
overhead cables that link all those
bumper cars to their energy sources and
while you may be a single bumper car you
have a cable going up that connects you
to the greater source of energy which
provides the power you need to move
forward and in the same way mastermind
is both that power coming to us from
above but also the power that comes to
us from each other when we mastermind
together and together we know more and
can focus more energy than any one
person can do alone now assembling a
mastermind group is easy you want to
choose people who are already where
you'd like to be in your life or who are
at least one level above you if your
goal is to become a millionaire you're
not gonna get a lot of help if everyone
in your mastermind group is only making
$60,000 a year now of course approaching
successful people can feel a little
scary at first in fact you might be
thinking why would anyone want to be in
a mastermind group with me if I'm only
making 60,000 a year but the answer is
that many people at a higher
productivity or success will want to
become involved simply because they then
get to play at a game they might never
organize for themselves called a
mastermind group now the other people
you're going to invite are people that
they would like to be around too but you
won't know if people will play or not
until you ask so you have to ask them
are you gonna get some nose probably but
if you ask enough people you'll get the
five or six people you need to have your
mastermind group so start with a list
and simply work down the list rule
number nine is do an evening review
successful people maintain a positive
focus in life no matter what is going on
around them they stay focused on their
past successes rather than on their past
failures and on the next action steps
that will get them closer to the whole
filmin of their goals rather than on all
the other distractions that life
presents to them they are constantly
proactive in the pursuit of their chosen
objectives an important part of any
focusing regimen is to set aside time at
the end of the day just before going to
sleep to meditate on your successes
review your goals focus on your desired
ideal future successes and make success
plans for what you want to accomplish
the next day now why do I suggest at the
end of the day because whatever you read
see listen to talk about an experience
during the last 45 minutes of the day
has a huge influence on your sleep and
on your next day according to some
recent research during the night your
unconscious mind replays and processes
this late-night input up to six times
more often than anything else you
experienced during the day this is why
cramming for school exams late at night
can work and why watching a scary movie
right before bed will often give you
nightmares
this is also why reading a good bedtime
story to children is important for them
not just to get them to fall asleep but
because the repeated messages lessons
values and morals of the story become
part of the fabric of the child's
consciousness and as you drift off to
sleep you enter into the alpha brain way
state of consciousness the state in
which you are very suggestible now if
you drift off to sleep after watching
The Late News
that's what's gonna be imprinting into
your consciousness war crime
automobile accidents rape robbery murder
gang wars drive-by shootings kidnappings
natural disasters and corporate scandals
I think how much better it would be to
read an inspiring autobiography or a
self-improvement book instead imagine
the power of meditating or listening to
a self-help audio program or taking the
time to plan your next day right before
you go to sleep
so here are two exercises that will keep
you positively focused and moving
forward at the end of the day the first
is a very impactful meditation technique
called the evening review this is a
powerful exercise to help you more
quickly instill new positive behavior
like punctuality a new habit like
listening more or new quality like
patience or mindfulness and you'll be
amazed at how fast this technique can
lead to a permanent change in your life
and it's very easy to do you start by
simply sitting with your eyes closed and
taking a few deep breaths and after you
feel more relaxed you give yourself one
of the following directions you say to
your subconscious mind show me where I
could have been more effective today or
show me where I could have been more
conscious today or showing me or I could
have been better and then you fill in
your profession like a better manager or
a better teacher a better coach or
better salesman today or a better parent
today show me where I could have been
more loving today or show me where I
could have been more assertive today or
show me where I could have been more and
then just fill in any quality more
loving more compassionate more patient
more perseverant today and as you sit
calmly in a state of quiet receptivity
you're gonna see that a number of events
from the day will come to mind just
observe them without any judgment or any
self-criticism and when no more events
come to mind then go back and take each
incident in their plate in your mind the
way you would have preferred to have
done it had you been more conscious and
more intentional at the time you just
visualize the movie how you would like
to have been instead of how you were and
rule number 10 the last one before the
bonus Clips create a breakthrough
next I want to encourage you to create a
breakthrough goal for the year a
well-formed goal is both powerful and
measurable specifically a goal must
quantify something and it must list a
specific date for completion going back
to the goal versus resolution example
from above the good goal is I will
participate in the charity 5k on April
21st and I will complete it in 30
minutes or less as the Admiral of a NGO
as that is your year has even greater
chances of success if you set a
breakthrough goal now breakthrough goal
is the goal that will quantum leap your
success a large goal that could change
your life dramatically
carefully consider possible breakthrough
goals for yourself what would
dramatically change your life instead of
just running a 5k set a breakthrough
goals such as losing 35 pounds or
totally eliminating the need for a
certain medication instead of just
volunteering at the polls set a
breakthrough goal to run for a local
office or set a breakthrough goal to
write a book or earn your master's
degree or get your real estate license
because a breakthrough goal has the
power to transform your life it also has
the power to make 2018 your best year
ever
now this fact alone makes setting a
breakthrough goal one of the most
powerful things you can do for your
future success and your future happiness
so follow these tips to make 2018 your
best year ever
now I've got some special jack canfield
bonus clips to you but before getting to
that my question of the day is around
rule number 9 which was doing evening
review I'm wondering what did you do as
an evening routine do you keep track of
what happened during the day do you
focus on what you were grateful for do
you focus on what you need to do
tomorrow what is your eating review do
you have one are you going to start one
I would love to hear from you
please leave it down the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clips
you noticed an enduring axiom of success
that says the universe rewards action
not thought now obviously it's important
to think but what really makes the
rubber hit the road and produce as a
result are the actions you take
and yet as simple as this principle
seems it's surprising how many people
get bogged down in the analyzing the
planning the organizing stages and what
they really need to do is simply get
into action now when you take action not
only do additional resources come your
way but you get feedback that helps you
adjust your course and refine your
approach now in my seminars I conduct a
very illustrious of exercise I'll hold
up a hundred dollar bill and I'll ask
the participants if anyone would like to
have it I'll say who would like this
hundred dollar bill then I just stand
there and eventually someone gets it
they'll get up and they'll come running
toward the front of the room and they'll
[ __ ] the hundred dollar bill out of my
hand while the rest of people just sit
there and then I tell the audience that
they too could have been the one that
got the money if only they'd taken
action now the truth is while most of us
know about earning money making things
happen and bringing about change in the
world only a surprising few get to have
all the abundance all the glory and all
the satisfaction that this world has to
offer simply because they are the select
few who consistently take action taking
action is the one thing the most
important thing that separates winners
from non winners that has from the
have-nots the high achievers from the
everyday people or perhaps you've
watched as a co-worker launched a new
project that included your ideas only to
realize that you stood by while you
could have taken action clean up your
messes
you see incomplete projects unfinished
business and piles of clutter messes can
weigh you down and take away from the
energy you have to move forward toward
your goals physical energy mental energy
emotional energy are all affected see
when you don't complete tasks you can't
be fully prepared to move into the
present and work on your future tasks
you've got to be complete in the past
present in the present so you can focus
on your future and what this means is in
order to be productive you must complete
any unfinished business or
that have been holding you back from the
past so make a list of all the in
completes all the unfinished tasks you
have and make sure to prioritize them
scheduled time and get those completed
here's your homework for you to complete
after watching this video pick your most
important goal and then close your eyes
and create a visual movie in your mind
of that goal being realized just like
Jim Carrey did and see yourself living
that dream see it from the inside of you
looking out through your eyes at what
you would be seeing such as someone
handing you a large bonus check or
holding your newly published book in
your hand or walking up to your dream
car reaching out opening the door
getting inside starting the car and
feeling the thrill of the car
accelerating from zero to sixty miles
per hour and remember to add in the
sound you would be hearing and then feel
the feelings you'll be feeling if you'd
already achieved it so make sure to
close your eyes and visualize the same
movie twice a day every day for a
minimum of 60 days raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people need passion and not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
that's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details